Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13.
На прошлом уроке мы с вами рассмотрели тест производительности WebGL
и каким образом с помощью данной технологии есть возможность определить использование виртуальных машин, антидетектов, ВПС и прочего.
В этом уроке мы продолжим эту же серию экспериментов,
однако уделим внимание совершенно противоположной технологии.
Если раньше мы говорили по поводу видео, то сейчас мы будем говорить по поводу аудио.
А именно, теста производительности аудио.
Как мы видим сейчас на своих экранах, на реальном компьютере,
производительность теста аудио составляет 2,30 миллисекунд.
Но из чего состоит отпечаток аудио?
Возможно, я вас удивлю, но отпечаток аудио практически не имеет отношения к отпечатку аудио.
К аудиосистеме, я имею в виду.
Что такое? Давайте немного поговорим.
Вспомним историю.
31 марта 2018 года данный сайт прекратил свое существование,
но наверняка он знаком всем вам, потому что еще в далеком 2015 году
группой студентов из Принстонского университета США
был обнаружен непонятный отпечаток, непонятная технология на таких ресурсах, как Google и Facebook.
Тогда все подумали, что это аудио отпечаток.
Почему? Потому что...
Он носит название аудиоконтекст.
Давайте же найдем сейчас данный веб-ресурс и проверим наш отпечаток.
Мы нажимаем кнопку Fingerprint Me и вот он, наш отпечаток.
Чудесно, красиво, все хорошо, но что же он в себе хранит?
Пользователи, также как и SwapGL, они хотят этот отпечаток менять.
Давайте разберемся, почему это абсолютно непонятно.
Глупое и, более того скажу, опасное занятие.
Первое.
Вот визуализация якобы нашего отпечатка, но давайте мы посмотрим на то,
как выглядит он немного по-другому.
По факту, вот наш аудио отпечаток.
Вот он.
Получен двумя различными методиками.
Некоторые пользователи думают, что отпечаток...
Вот он.
Он более, скажем так, понятен, он больше похож на какой-нибудь хэш, например, на хэш MD5, что-нибудь такого плана.
И, соответственно, людям более привычно это.
Но, если вы воспользуетесь историей, а точнее воспользуетесь вашим компьютером и скачаете туда все последние, например, последние 100 версий браузера Chrome,
то вы увидите, что данный отпечаток, к примеру, вот тот, который сейчас вы видите у себя на экране,
он будет одинаковым.
Он будет одинаков в браузере Chrome, в браузере Opera, в браузере Edge.
На моем компьютере и на ваших компьютерах тоже.
И если мы будем проверять с вами этот отпечаток на...
Сейчас у нас 138-я версия Chrome.
Если мы с вами будем скачивать по одной версии назад, то есть 137-ю, 136-ю, 135-ю,
то мы с вами можем дойти аж до 98-й версии.
С 98-й по 138-ю этот отпечаток нигде не будет меняться.
В то же время на 98-й версии он изменится и будет изменяться аж до 92-й версии.
Суть данный отпечаток, это отпечаток аудиодвижка.
И если аудиодвижок не меняется, то и отпечаток этот меняться тоже не должен.
К сожалению, некоторые владельцы сайтов-чекеров,
они используют...
данный отпечаток в своих маркетинговых целях,
потому что его очень легко подменить.
Подменяется он элементарно просто даже правкой реестра.
Но делать этого, конечно же, не стоит.
Объясню по какой причине.
Дело в том, что если у этого отпечатка нет вариативности,
то есть у него есть всего-навсего одно значение,
то и подменять его является полным идиотизмом.
Но в то же время на этот идиотизм некоторые пользователи с удовольствием клюют,
не разобравшись в технологии самого...
отпечатка.
Но!
Имеет ли данный отпечаток какое-либо отношение к аудио?
Фактически не имеет.
Объясню вам почему.
Если вы возьмете компьютер,
на котором нет аудиокарты,
и выполните там этот тест,
у вас этот тест будет завершен успешно.
И там будут вот такого рода параметры.
Почему же так происходит?
Дело в том, что
данный отпечаток не воспроизводит какой-либо звук.
Он не записывает какой-либо звук.
Он выполняется внутри самого браузера.
И это, можно сказать, отпечаток,
который формируется самим браузером.
И практически, повторюсь, практически
не имеет отношения к ПК-пользователю.
Но все-таки определенная зависимость от ПК-пользователя
есть.
А именно, вот в этих двух отпечатках.
Про вот этот и его аналог выше, вы можете забыть,
они абсолютно бесполезны в нашем с вами деле.
Но вот эти отпечатки,
они хранят в себе намного больше секретов,
чем вы можете себе представить.
Дело в том, что данные отпечатки
являются отпечатками процессора.
Именно процессора.
Поскольку они зависят
от
от скорости выполнения инструкций на вашем CPU.
Вы когда-нибудь думали, что есть отпечаток процессора?
Вот я вам его показываю.
Конечно, сейчас некоторые люди могут возразить
Вектор, ты говоришь полную чушь,
потому что эти отпечатки можно изменить, например,
путем изменения констант обработки аудио.
И вы будете правы. Что я имею в виду?
Например, у меня сейчас
частота дискретизации 48000 Гц.
Эта частота дискретизации выставлена
в настройках звуковой карты на моем компьютере.
Можно выставить другую частоту,
можно выставить, например,
192000 Гц,
44100 Гц и так далее.
Можно, в принципе, играться.
Но на всех современных компьютерах,
если мы берем семейство Windows,
будет использоваться либо частота 48000 Гц,
либо 44100 Гц.
Другие частоты, они практически не используются.
То есть шансы того, что они используются,
0,0001.
Да и если бы они использовались,
таких частот существует всего-навсего,
я имею в виду не интерполированных,
всего-навсего 8 штук.
При изменении этой частоты,
при изменении частоты дискретизации,
вы действительно можете получить
другой отпечаток.
Почему так происходит?
А потому что инструкция, которая будет
выполнять вычисление данного отпечатка
внутри вашего браузера,
будет выполнять его с другими
исходными данными.
То есть, иными словами,
с другой частотой дискретизации.
Именно это является причиной того,
что ваш отпечаток будет изменен.
Но по факту,
это не играет абсолютно никакой роли.
Дело в том, что количество данных отпечатков
на вашем ПК и на всех ПК,
которые существуют, оно ограничено.
Иными словами, вы можете на своем компьютере,
на своем физическом компьютере,
можете сделать 2 разных отпечатка популярных
и 8 отпечатков непопулярных.
Точнее 6, прошу прощения.
Что же делать дальше?
С помощью вот этой технологии
Audio Context можно, например, получить
количество колонок,
то есть устройств вывода.
Можно здесь сделать одно устройство вывода,
два, четыре, семь.
Ну, это не имеет разницы.
И абсолютно никаким образом
не играет на формировании данного отпечатка.
Можно изменить, например, битрейт.
Его здесь, кстати, даже нету
на данном чекере еще.
Изменение битрейта воспроизведения
точно также никаким образом
не влияет на сам отпечаток.
Но это мы сейчас поговорили с вами
только лишь о отпечатках
и их вариативности.
Как вы думаете,
есть ли смысл
изменять данный отпечаток,
если его выполнение,
фактически формирование и выполнение
на всех современных ПК
будет плюс-минус одинаковое?
То есть да, конечно,
если вы возьмете, например,
сейчас какой-нибудь 64-ядерный процессор
современный и затем сравните его
с двухядерным старым Intel,
ну, здесь, очевидно, разница будет.
Но если мы берем, например,
то же самое более унифицированное
семейство Intel, например, i7,
отпечаток везде плюс-минус будет одинаковый.
За исключением усеченных моделей.
Точно так же в пятом семействе,
точно так же в семействе Ryzen, например,
и так далее.
Можно приводить различного рода примеры.
Тогда, когда он появился,
в 2013 году он впервые был создан,
замечен он был в 2015 году как рабочий.
Он использовался действительно
для определения ботов.
Но каким образом он использовался?
А я вам сейчас покажу.
Точно так же, как использовался
отпечаток WebGL,
точно так же использовался и отпечаток аудио.
Дело в том, что,
выполняя процедуру получения данного отпечатка
и выполняя процедуру получения производительности,
которую вы видите сейчас на своих экранах,
есть возможность определения, опять же,
использования ботов.
Насрать всем на то, какой у вас отпечаток.
Можете его менять хоть 10 000 раз.
В этом никакого эффекта вы не добьетесь.
А вот производительность его,
вот это уже совершенно другой и интересный момент.
Но если в случае с WebGL
количество кадров оно падало,
то есть значение уменьшалось этого показателя,
то в разрезе аудио отпечатка
оно будет увеличиваться.
Ведь поскольку, если ваш процессор,
не является быстрым,
либо же используется какая-либо виртуальная машина,
то время на выполнение данного запроса
и получение данного бенчмарка
будет составлять примерно 45-50 миллисекунд.
А соответственно, с помощью данной,
опять же, элементарной технологии,
такой же элементарной, как WebGL,
в 2015 году
Google не пытался идентифицировать пользователей.
Он пытался отделить ботов
от реальных пользователей.
И в частности, данная технология, что интересно,
являлась, скажем так, фундаментом
для появления таких сервисов, как reCAPTCHA.
Поскольку она действительно отличнейшим образом
позволяла определить ботов.
Ведь, давайте возьмем нашу табличку сравнения.
Технология получения аудио-бенчмарка
позволяет определить использование VPS.
Как мы понимаем, на VPS используются
не физические ядра, скажем так,
а в основном это sharing ядер.
Либо же, если мы вдруг найдем сервис,
на котором будут действительно использоваться
реальные ядра процессора,
за счет того, что инструкции будут выполнять,
не напрямую на процессоре,
а будут выполняться в эмуляции,
то значение аудио будет повышено
до 45-50 миллисекунд за выполнение.
В отличие от 1,5 или 2,5 секунд,
которые будут затрачены на выполнение
данной инструкции на реальном ПК.
Также, с помощью данной технологии аудио-бенчмарка
есть возможность вычислить
использование виртуальных машин.
Виртуалбокс, ВМВР, Проксмокс,
Квему и всех остальных.
Почему так происходит?
Дело в том, что, опять же,
данная инструкция будет сначала
выполнена внутри виртуального компьютера,
и только затем будет передана
на выполнение на реальный ПК.
И за счет вот этой разницы в передаче данных
будет сформировано довольно долгое время
отклика и долгое время выполнения.
Что будет свидетельствовать о том,
что перед нами используется либо ВПС,
либо виртуальная машина,
что по факту есть одно и то же.
Соответственно, пункт номер три.
Использование антидетект браузеров
внутри ВПС является абсолютно глупым занятием.
Потому что, даже если вы не будете
включать подмену отпечатка аудио,
что есть правильное действие,
но вы будете все равно запускаться на ВПС,
у вас будут видеть виртуальную машину.
Это факт.
И с ним не поспоришь.
Далее.
Удаленный сервер плюс антидетект браузер.
У меня он дублирован здесь.
Как в хорошем пункте, так же и в плохом.
Теперь давайте включим немного логику.
Почему же использование удаленного сервера
и антидетект браузера может вызывать
какого-либо рода проблемы.
Дело в том, что
по умолчанию при использовании удаленных серверов
конечно же у нас есть возможность
использовать ресурсы процессора напрямую.
Это нормально, это хорошо.
Но здесь есть одна очень важная деталь.
Эта деталь заключается в том,
что если вы запускаете,
а точнее используете данную технологию
на серверном оборудовании,
время отклика у вас будет нечто среднее
между реальным компьютером и виртуальной машиной.
По какой причине?
Дело в том, что на скорость выполнения данной операции
влияет частота процессора.
И в большинстве случаев,
когда пользователи арендуют удаленные сервера,
они обращают внимание почему-то
только лишь на количество ядер,
но не на тактовую частоту процессора.
А соответственно, если вы будете выполнять данный тест
на удаленном сервере с низкой тактовой частотой,
например 2 ГГц,
какой-нибудь старый Intel Xeon,
то к сожалению антибот-система
увидит, что используется серверное оборудование.
Почему?
Потому что вот этот вот бенчмарк
он не будет соответствовать
ни реальному компьютеру,
ни ВПС,
а будет соответствовать
четко именно
удаленным серверам.
Конечно же, здесь можно сделать поправку,
что такого бенчмарка можно добиться
и при использовании очень старого оборудования.
И да, действительно так и есть,
но скажем так,
в антибот-системах нет
практически параметров,
которые являлись бы абсолютными.
То есть, иными словами,
все складывается, общая картина
и мнение пользователей складывается
из различных параметров,
из различных идентификаторов,
каждый из которых имеет свой собственный вес.
И поэтому,
если есть возможность этого избежать,
то лучше избежать.
Но если вы будете использовать антидетект браузеры
на
низких
на серверах с низкой тактовой частотой,
вас смогут определить.
Ну и конечно же,
антидетект от Vector T13
в версии до V
есть возможность определить использование виртуальной машины,
поскольку точно так же
будет долгое время отклика процессора.
Какие системы нельзя определить
с помощью данного отпечатка,
данного бенчмарка?
Нельзя определить EFI спуферы,
что это такое, я не буду сейчас рассказывать,
в прошлом уроке, где был пример с WebGL,
мы об этом конкретно поговорили.
Дальше.
Нельзя будет использовать данный бенчмарк
для определения удаленного сервера,
но только лишь,
если этот сервер с высокой тактовой частотой.
Не забывайте об этом.
И соответственно, пункт номер 3.
У меня их целых три.
Удаленный сервер
с антидетект браузером,
точно так же, как можно использовать,
так же его нельзя использовать.
Нельзя, мы поняли, почему можно,
если у нас высокая тактовая частота,
то данный тест
будет выполнен на отлично,
никаких проблем не будет.
Либо же, если антидетект браузер запущен
на реальном компьютере,
то тоже самое.
Реальный ПК, реальная частота процессора,
быстрое время отклика,
все отлично.
И также,
если вы будете запускать данный тест
на антидетекте с CPU Boost.
Дело в том, что
есть возможность
практически во всех виртуальных машинах
сделать CPU Boost.
То есть, первый вариант
это сделать трассировку
таким образом,
чтобы все инструкции выполнялись
не на виртуальном процессоре,
а на реальном процессоре.
Такая возможность действительно есть.
Либо же, второй вариант
это выделение большого количества
ресурсов
и работа с таймингами
внутри самого исходного кода
виртуальной машины.
Это уже очень сложная машинерия
и доступно это только сейчас
в антидетекте от Vector T13.
Как же определить
данный
аудиоконтекст?
Тест, который мы проводили
с вами с помощью определения
затрат на
выполнение данного действия
к сожалению, в данном случае
не работает.
Увы, потому что если мы попытаемся
выполнить конкретно эту инструкцию
на ее выполнение у нас уйдет
те же самые 16-20
миллисекунд. То есть, практически
вы не сможете ее обнаружить.
Однако, данная технология
великолепно, простым образом
определяется с помощью любого браузерного
плагина для Firefox или Chrome,
который позволяет определить
использование аудиоконтекст
на странице веб-ресурса.
Поэтому, когда вы будете
смотреть на необходимый вам
веб-ресурс
и увидите там аудиоконтекст
не думайте,
что данный
веб-ресурс
получает отпечаток аудио.
Помните, что это
в большинстве случаев
является всего-навсего антибот
проверкой на предмет
производительности вашего
компьютера и отделения средств
автоматизации от реальных пользователей.
На этом все.
Спасибо за внимание.
С вами был VectorT13.